justement parlant de bague il ya deux
journées un internaute qui a publié sur
twitter une capture d'écran d'un message
de drague plutôt originale qu'elle a
reçues signataires de qu'elle a reçues
sur instagram regarde moi non et
s'assure un stage je suis mort d un max
revient arrête de déranger les jolies
filles en fait le tweet c'est est ce que
vous pouvez qu'on peut expliquer ce que
c'est un buzz énorme ludivine les tories
en fait on lui envoie genre le chien
parce que ça ça sert toujours à draguer
les soeurs les enfants cantonné aux
parts et donc il ya en valent 5
le chien genre max regarde si j'arrête
on dérange pas les il le rappelle quand
il le rappelle à l'ordre bien c'est très
sympa alors le buzz a fait ça fait à
bosser dans vingt-huit mille retweet
82000 like depuis plein d'autres mecs
ont tenté cette technique approche avec
plus est nécessaire mais c'est vrai est
ce que vous vous avez une technique d'
approche particulière vous par exemple
il faut vous approchez vous ruer lui
l'école mais je vous fais une confidence
quand j'ai voulu approcher aurore voix
de femme madame je lui ai envoyé un
bouquet de fleurs virtuelles sur sur
iphone et laisser émoticônes fleurs et
elle n'avait pas et c'est vraiment une
barre à côté ça va laissez moi finir bon
non la jambe et des fleurs virtuellement
mais elle n'avait pas l'iphone donc elle
avait un interclubs un système android
c'est donc elle a les points
d'interrogation déclamation d'efforts il
m'a répondu c'est très gentil à toi non
oui un baladeur la ponctuation
g
et ça marche et ça c'est une prof de
français l'adorent la variation des
points d'exclamation des petits points
et ben ouais bah ça a marché après deux
suspensions tous à vous c'est quoi vous
alors à vos techniques d' approche les
plus jean michel maire non moi je traque
très peu sur internet parce que c'est
notre action en 2002 c'est un message
les gens me demandent 'est-ce que tu as
numéro de cyril c'est vrai c'est bournat
contient les événements sur un coach ne
donne jamais quand ça ne pose que le
mien tiens à vous [ __ ] de ma gueule
normes mêmes bases techniques d'
approche presse que vous avez une phrase
de prédilection pour aller draguer une
fille ou un truc comme ça c'est combien
ça passe
[Applaudissements]
jean michel est né demande chaque jour
je veux vraiment le faire venir au début
les messieurs c'est pas son truc et des
munitions qui doit devenir en guest star
oui bien sûr mais moi j'avais la
technique de boîte de nuit un petit peu
quand il a un petit peu tard et qui est
un peu moins de choix oui j'allais voir
une personne est jugée c'est ton jour de
censure pour à boxer temps de ta
catégorie donc la personne était
incroyable tu vas voir pour une personne
comme ça est tellement impressionné
c'est qu'elle parte
ah oui ah non j'ai dit la vérité non non
c'est vrai c'est assez fois oui ah oui
c'est en général ces personnes n'ont pas
accès à des célébrités bon rebelles webb
avec mme géraldine maillet moi j'aime
pas les techniques rouge qui peut
éventuellement me faire c'est dur c'est
les smileys vous savez des émoticônes
genre spaghetti sushi blaquart il va les
bouffer qu'on peut se faire chez moi par
cyril lignac en fait baver c'est vrai
o'kelly bah moi l'histoire du petit
chien je pense que ça a été ça a été
bien pour moi il aurait pu couler gino
d'un chien ou d'ailleurs dans quoi alors
vous avez un chien alors on a tous des
chiens oui j'ai un petit truc non pas
des chiens souvent ça sert pour draguer
la relève ne sert pas du tout mais moi
je n'aurais pas avant les mecs vérité
voilà mais c'est vrai que moi j'ai un
chien un bras ce qui s'appelle nahla qui
est magnifique
voilà et c'est vrai que je la garde que
pour moi vous vous sécurité cnis moi
j'essaie de faire mon intéressant chez
c'est de faire rire j'ai c'est si je
devais le faire c'est ce que je fais en
fait c'est devenu frère et ça fonctionne
pas du tout mal commenté moins
dépressifs
[Applaudissements]
après si tu as une base attendait ça ni
d'enfants ou l'art ni demain déjà savoir
en tulle à mes concitoyens quant à 40 de
vienne cela leur a vendu la bagatelle au
mas et l'attenté comme instant rattrape
loi et tu manges du molino les petits
plats tout chaud alors le joli mais pas
fait frères sont rigolos on aurait cru
j'ai cru qu'on était dans ça commence
aujourd'hui faustine bollaert
bah oui bah je sais pas vous allez y
allez bientôt on recommence aujourd'hui
mais ça va se finir
[Applaudissements]
méchante dépressif moi je me bats
technique de vrai parce que je laisse
toujours alors on va remettre tous en
place
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
papa tu na li qu aller valley
technique de drague c'est que je laisse
toujours venir mais en revanche moi un
mec un jour pato crusiaux la faire
illusion on prit alors le mec m'a envoyé
un texto il ya cinq ans et mamie mon
fils avait un pikachu à noël et moi
j'aimerais avoir toi c'est quoi le prix
à payer
alors la balle à la vôtre je ne peux
plus rien parce que j'ai déjà un podium
ah ouais au poker c'est génial c'est
sympa tout ça vous et jean michel maire
c'est qu'on vous dit des trucs vous
dites leur haute voix mais il a dit a
demandé 5 euros à la serre aux sortants
bouquin ça va pas faire danser les gens
franchement c'est une catastrophe
vous avez eu un truc aussi avec un
serveur il paraît qu'ils moi ouais dans
mes techniques mais si j'étais jeune
c'était à l'époque j'étais en vacances à
saint martin qui est très belle petite
île
évidemment quand on est un peu en
géographie on n'est pas dupe et et le
mec était très très mignon j'étais
célibataire à l'époque donc j'étais
totalement ouverte à des petites gens
nantis alors on dit toujours ça on était
célibataire elle est partie à
saint-martin steve ai dit tout à l'heure
sinon est en fait il m'avait demandé
s'il y avait quelque chose qui me
plaisait ce que je désirais manger et je
lui avais dit que ce que je voulais
n'était pas sur le menu en fait quoi
aulas audacieuse mois oui j'avais dit ça
mais oui c'est très belle sexy gonflé
ouais bah oui mais vous savez c'était de
véritables a été mon crash et quads
non mais vous vous avez une technique
aussi vous regarde répliques de films y
paraît oui oui et non c'est à dire que
ce que j'ai vu samedi
je préfère prévenir ces sites les gens
on n'a pas connaître là là on ne sent
pas de but la séquence avec toi ton
animateurs avant aussi on va donner la
parole à quelqu'un et on sait qu'on va
dans le mur
oui
on s'est dit allez pourquoi pas à
l'émission a bien démarré on sort 3852
allez on y va
et vous n'allez moi si je me trompe ou
pas peut-être que ce raid joëlle et
bernard j'ai très bien là bas vous êtes
super ici en allemagne sur mon dieu
c'est un bond de partout à vous êtes
beau aussi me demande si comme ça de
loin c'est quand on se fait peur comme
ça sur une bonne de là bas pour voir si
elle est plus drôle dans alors on
n'écoute pas la manquer tout essayé on
voit ce qu'on voit c'est la veille non
d'abord je n'aime pas comme drague tu
peux tout chasseur donc en général ça me
dérange c'est quelqu'un de humble et je
suis timide
timide excuse a dit ban de thons marque
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tvous domino et un tabouret plus vous en
sortirez les moments où vous irez on
voit là ok très bien alors voilà donc
c'est sa baisse et ça c'est ce que je
vous disais ah non mais c'est quoi on
n'a pas ça c'est quoi mais je vous dis
simplement que je n'aime pas qu'on me
raconte donc c'est moi le chasseur je
joue un peu au timide oui alors oui donc
voilà c'est tout mais il paraît que vous
sortez des répliques de films
oui parfois au hasard mais quoi et alors
je vais en regorge de les oublier
enfin avant début d'émission télé oublié
certes un peu l'image eesi lundi ouais
c'est l'indifférence mais cyril vous
quand vous étiez plus jeune et quand
vous aviez une libido ce qui n'est plus
le cas aujourd'hui
bien sûr vous aviez une technique de
drague pas du tout c'est alors moi je
suis pas un dragueur du tout mais
vraiment d'accord c'est connu je ne suis
pas un dragueur un secteur qui quoi à la
gente féminine je ne suis pas un
dragueur et mathieu qui me connaît bien
c'est que je suis pas un dragueur à
banon s'est passé
[Rires]
soubadou l'huile pas si je ne suis pas
un dragueur on m'a dit j'ai jamais été
dragon mois l'indifférence en a pas
toutes les meufs à ses pieds oui c'est
pas la peine un dragueur aussi en même
temps rodez tu très bonne émission nous